kann Putin tatsächlich hinter diesem
Abschluss stecken
ja wer colonium benutzt um Verräter
angebliche in London zu vergiften wer
Menschen im Ausland und im Inland
umbringen lässt wer seit 10 20 Jahren
immer wieder Oppositionelle Journalisten
andere
zu Tode kommen lässt da ist es natürlich
sehr wahrscheinlich dass das auch in
diesem Fall so ist und es war doch klar
nach dem seinen Putschversuch gestoppt
hatte dass in Russland nicht mehr für
beides Platz sein würde und jetzt sehen
wir das Ergebnis
unser reicht ja eine Frage bei Youtube
die so lautet welchen Sinn ergeben ist
das ganze nur zu inszenieren
wir sind zur Zeit immer bei einem was
passiert sehr schnell darin eine
Inszenierung zu vermuten oder eine ganz
komplizierte Geschichte die da
eigentlich im Hintergrund läuft ich
halte das in diesem Fall für überhaupt
gar nicht wahrscheinlich jetzt gehen die
pregorien hatte keinen Grund jetzt so
eine komplizierte Sache zu inszenieren
ich glaube auch nicht dass er das
gekonnt hätte was wir sehen ist das was
es ist es war ein Flugzeug in dem die
Wagner Führungsmannschaft drin war und
dieses Flugzeug ist abgestürzt und alle
die dort die Insassen waren sind
gestorben ich glaube das nicht dass das
ein Inszenierung war
Putin hat wenn es wirklich so sein
sollte dass er dahinter steckt damit ihr
einen möglichen ja jemanden aus dem Weg
geräumt der ihm gefährlich werden könnte
aber profitiert er tatsächlich auch
politisch davon
also putin ist es wichtig die Botschaft
zu senden wer sich mit mir anlegt der
muss dran glauben das ist das A und O
für sein macht Erhalt und das war bei
Goji besonders wichtig weil pregorian ja
mit diesem Putschversuch öffentlich vor
allem Augen in Russland aber auch vor
den Augen der Welt herausgefordert hat
und ja auch blamiert hat mit diesem
putscht versucht weiß ich ja keiner
damals den WAG geworfen hat um Putin zu
verteidigen das Putin das nicht direkt
danach macht sondern mit einigen
zeitlichen Abstand das kennt man von ihm
da hat er offensichtlich die Geduld also
vieles passt da in das Muster ob er
politisch davon profitiert über die
Botschaft hinaus wer sich mit mir anlegt
der muss dann glauben das ist eine
offene Frage was ich natürlich jetzt
viele in Russland
bisschen Gedanken darüber machen Putin
hat einen Krieg begonnen den er nicht
gewinnt die Sanktionen treffen Russland
schon sehr hart es ist nicht mehr so
viel Geld wie vorher das Leben in
Russland ist schwieriger geworden viele
stehen auch Sanktionslisten und können
nicht mehr reisen und man kommt an Putin
überhaupt gar nicht mehr ran man kann
mit ihm überhaupt nicht mehr sprechen
muss man sich das eigentlich noch sechs
weitere Jahre antun im nächsten Jahr
sind ja Präsidentschaftswahlen in
Russland also es könnte auch sein dass
das politisch erst der Anfang ist von
Überlegungen und vielleicht auch von
Instabilität die wir in Russland sehen
können
eine weitere Frage die wir bei Youtube
bekommen haben und zwar von Andreas
lautet wird die Kampfmoral der Russen
wenn wir jetzt auf den Blick den Blick
auf den Krieg in die Ukraine richten
wird die Kampfmoral der Russen jetzt
nicht noch mehr geschwächt so viel
trouble mitten in Kriegszeiten hinter
den Kulissen kann doch nicht besonders
förderlich sein für die russische Truppe
was würden Sie dazu sagen
und direkter Auswirkung dieses Absturzes
auf die Kampfhandlungen der Ukraine sehe
ich erstmal nicht aber es stimmt was der
User schreibt Unruhen in Russland auch
schon dieser Putsch und diese
fortwährenden Auseinandersetzung da
haben die Soldaten nicht das Gefühl dass
ihnen der Rücken gestärkt wird sie
fühlen sich eher ein bisschen allein
gelassen und natürlich ist es so dass
viele auch unter den normalen Soldaten
Sympathien hatten für gregorien und für
die wagnertruppe so irre das aus unserer
Perspektive klingt aber der war sowas
wie ein Mafia Pate so eine viel
väterliche Figur und vor allen Dingen
hat er immer mit seinen Soldaten im Feld
geschlafen er war immer nah bei den
Soldaten während die normale russische
Streitkräfte Führung ja sich immer weit
entfernt aufhält und dann eine große
Distanz hat also da hatte er schon viele
Sympathien und dass der jetzt auf diese
Weise zu Tode gekommen ist das ist
vielleicht auch so bisschen so ein
Signal der Hoffnungslosigkeit in dem
Sinne dass ich nichts ändern wird
dazu passt auch noch die Frage von
Julian die lautet sind Racheaktionen
verbleibender Wagner sollten oder
Unterstützer innerhalb der russischen
Armee wahrscheinlich für Deutschland hat
sich hat ja oft die schlechten Zustände
dort beklagt
das ist eine wichtige Frage wie jetzt
die Anführer die es noch gibt in der
wagnergruppe und die Söldner wie die
jetzt unter Kontrolle gebracht werden
können ich meine spätestens seit gestern
ist vollkommen offensichtlich dass diese
Vereinbarung mit der Putin ja auch in
die Öffentlichkeit gegangen ist trikotin
geht ins Ausland die wagnerkämpfer gehen
nach Belarus oder können in die
russischen Streitkräfte integriert
werden dass die nie das Papier wert war
auf dem sie geschrieben stand trikotin
war ja die ganze Zeit in Russland oder
in Afrika oder irgendwo anders unterwegs
keiner hat sich an irgendwas gehalten
was dabei hat war das ist die Frage was
machen diese Wagner sollten die jetzt in
Belarus sind gab ja auch Meldung den ist
schon mal das Mobilfunknetz abgeschaltet
worden aber einige haben sich wohl in
Richtung Russland in Bewegung gesetzt
was passiert mit denen die sich in die
russischen Streitkräfte integrieren
sollten und gleichzeitig ein Stück weit
unabhängig davon wird die Frage
beantwortet wie geht eigentlich das
Geschäft der wagnergruppe vor allen
Dingen in Afrika weiter wo ich glaube
das ist weitergeführt wird und gibt's
dann Angebote an die seltener die ja für
Geld vor allen Dingen unterwegs sind
diese Fragen sind aber zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt noch nicht so ganz geklärt die
wagnergruppe musste aber seit einigen
Wochen z.B schweres Gerät schon an die
Nation übergeben und ist natürlich auch
dadurch dass sie in Belarus weit weg ist
erstmal abseits des Geschehens deswegen
erwarte ich jetzt nicht unmittelbar das
ist der Aufstände gibt oder irgendeiner
Art von Widerstand
ich möchte Ihnen gerne bevor wir zu
unserer Kollegin in die Ukraine schalten
noch eine Frage mitgeben wie kann es
sein dass die komplette wagnerführung in
einem Flieger sitzt macht das Ganze
nicht unglaubwürdig fragt uns noch
jemand bei YouTube
ja da gibt es unterschiedliche Gründe
ein Grund könnte sein dass Herr
pregorian Gründe hatte jetzt auch nicht
allen davor behalten zu vertrauen und
das ist ja oft so in solchen
Organisationen das ist ja wie bei
Organisationen in der organisierten
Kriminalität wenn man nicht so ganz
vertraut was machen eigentlich da die
Stellvertreter oder die anderen dann
hält man die immer ganz dicht und hält
sie unter Kontrolle dann machen die
keinen Unfug kann mir vorstellen dass so
etwas eine Rolle gespielt hat in dieser
Organisation und gleichzeitig sind die
ja seit einigen Tagen und Wochen immer
wieder unterwegs gewesen offenbar auch
alle gemeinsam in Afrika anderswo in
Russland offenbar
öfter mit diesem Flugzeug oder mit
anderen Flugzeugen vielleicht haben sie
sich ein Stück weit zu sicher geführt
dass sie sich so bewegen können
möglicherweise war das ja auch der Trick
ihnen das Gefühl zu geben sie sind
sicher sie können da reisen können immer
wieder diese Flüge Unternehmen dass sie
dann also gedacht haben da passiert
schon nichts wenn Sie das so machen
eine Frage die uns auch bei Youtube
erreicht lautet welche Konsequenzen
werden für die zukünftige Lage Russlands
und des Ukraine Krieges gesehen also wie
muss man diese beiden Ereignisse gestern
der Flugzeugabsturz in der vergangenen
Nacht diese sehr prominent verkündete
spezialoperation welche Auswirkungen hat
das möglicherweise
also der Flugzeugabsturz hat nur
Auswirkungen auf die
Kampfhandlungen in der Ukraine wenn sich
die Instabilität in Russland fortsetzt
wenn jetzt noch mehr Dinge passieren
wenn es weitere Diskussionen gibt wenn
sozusagen mit diesem Mafia-Methoden
weitere Eiform Arbeiten durchgeführt
werden wenn vielleicht auch in der
militärspitze Generation ist ja ein Tag
vorher entlasten worden noch weitere
Entlastung da sind also wenn die Unruhe
anhält dann könnte das eine negative
Wirkung auf die russischen Streitkräfte
haben
was die ukrainischen Operation auf der
Creme angeht passen die ja zu dem was
die Ukraine schon seit geraumer Zeit
macht ja auch mit den Marschflugkörpern
zum Beispiel den Storm Shadow und den
Sky Budget nämlich die Logistik die
Führung die Kommunikation der russischen
Seite immer wieder anzugreifen und zu
schwächen und auf der Krim geht's
besonders auch noch darum von dort
starten Flugzeuge die die Ukraine
beschießen von dort sind Raketen auf
Odessa abgeschlossen worden und man kann
sich ja nicht die ganze Zeit beschießen
lassen ohne mal die Ursache zu bekämpfen
und da geht's also auch um diese Bastion
Systeme die die Raketen auf dem Wasser
geschossen haben kann
ist denn tatsächlich davon auszugehen
dass die Ukraine mit weiteren
spezialoperationen versucht noch weiter
auf die Krim vorzurücken wie ist da ihre
Prognose
das ist davon auszugehen dass der
ukrainische Militärgeheimdienst ständig
spezialoperationen durchführt aber daher
ein Geheimdienst ist macht er das im
Geheimen die Besonderheit Bestand heute
darin dass es jetzt an die
Öffentlichkeit kam mit Absicht mit
Videos und mit einer klaren Botschaft
zum Unabhängigkeitstag solche
Operationen auch teilweise tief in
feingebiet also in von Russland
besetzten Gebieten werden im Grunde
ständig durchgeführt und das wird auch
so weitergehen
eine Anmerkung die uns noch bei Youtube
erreicht lautet das die Kritik des
US-Militärs des die würde lauten die
Ukraine bündelt ihre Angriffe nicht
stark genug ist die Strategie der
Ukraine durch die fuseaktion die
russische Verteidigung auseinander zu
ziehen
zunächst einmal
würde ich sagen wir tun gut daran wenn
wir uns mit mit Kritik zu Strategie und
Taktik der ukrainischen Streitkräfte
zurückhalten
wir haben keine Erfahrung damit wie man
in so einem offenen Gelände wo alles so
weithin einsichtig ist bei diesen vielen
Minenfeldern gegen solche Befestigungen
ohne Luftüberlegenheit eigentlich
militärische Fortschritte erzielt und
ich finde es passt auch nicht ganz
zusammen wenn man sagt die Ukraine
sollen wir jetzt mal schneller und
stärker und entschlossener gegen die
russischen Verteidigungslinien vorgehen
wenn man bei der Unterstützung der
Ukraine selbst immer ängstlich und
langsam und zögerlich ist
also wir sollten uns darauf
konzentrieren wie wir die Ukraine
unterstützen können und uns mit solchen
zurufen von der Seitenlinie eher
zurückhalten die Ukraine hat sich darauf
verlegt mit kleineren Einheiten kleine
Vorstöße zu machen und jede russische
Stellung einzeln anzugehen weil die
großen Durchbrüche am Anfang vor einigen
wegen der Mischung aus Minenfeldern und
russischer Luftüberlegenheit mit
Hubschraubern mit Flugzeugen das hat
einfach nicht zum Erfolg geführt jetzt
probiert man was anderes mit diesem
kleineren Vorstößen und wir sehen ja
gerade in den letzten Tagen dass die
Ukraine an zwei Stellen an der Südfront
zwar langsam aber dann doch Vorankommen
kommt und gleichzeitig ist die Ukraine
sehr aktiv und die Logistik den
munitionsnachzug dem Treibstoff
Nachschub der Russen immer wieder
anzugreifen und zu schwächen und auch
das scheint einigen Erfolg zu haben die
große Schlacht oder der große Durchbruch
ist bisher ausgeblieben und wir müssen
glaube ich uns darauf einstellen dass
das sehr lange dauert was die Ukraine
davor hat wir dürfen aber auch nicht den
Fehler machen zu denken dass er jetzt
ein Part und jetzt geht da gar nichts
mehr voran die Ukraine kommt voran aber
eben langsam wir haben eine Frage noch
die genau darauf abzielt auf das was sie
gerade sagten von Julian halten Sie die
Abschneidung der russischen
Nachschublinien durch die Lieferung von
Taurus überhaupt für möglich also diese
Marschflugkörper die die Ukraine auch
gerne von Deutschland geliefert haben
möchte welche Relevanz könnte die
Lieferung sonst noch haben wie schätzen
Sie das ein
also ich halte das für möglich nicht
durch Taurus allein aber Taurus ist ja
auch gar nicht als sozusagen gamechanger
oder als der besonders neue besonders
andere Waffe gedacht sondern die
britischen Streitkräfte liefern ja schon
Storm Shadow Marshall Körper die
französischen liefern aber damit die
Ukraine die Ziele im Süden der Ukraine
und auf der Creme eben dauerhaft
bekämpfen kann immer wieder und alle
davon braucht sie einen ständigen
Nachschub von diesem Körpern und Taurus
ist aus meiner Sicht eher Instrument
damit dafür zu sorgen dass die Ukraine
eben über längere Sicht immer für diesen
muskelkörpern welche zur Verfügung hat
wir müssen also einen Beitrag zu leisten
es gibt eine Besonderheit von Taurus
nämlich dass die Sprengköpfe besser dazu
geeignet scheinen z.B drücken zu
zerstören
stormschere und Skype besteht die
treffen da sehr genau aber die schlagen
da ein Loch durch man müsste ja diese
Brücken wirklich ganz zerstören um die
logistischen Linien abzuschneiden und
das geht mit Taurus meiner Meinung nach
besser
verlange ich würde abschließend ihnen
noch gerne die Frage von Tobias
weitergeben um noch mal zur wagnertruppe
zu kommen und zwar lautet die Frage Witz
die wagnergruppe sich jetzt gegen die
russische Führung stellen
also Teile der wagnergruppe haben das ja
bei dem Putsch getan Teile der
wagnergruppe haben das jetzt auch in
Messengern und in sozialen Netzwerken
getan teilweise mit drastischen Worten
man weiß dass Herr pregorian einen
Testament hinterlassen hat und das ist
einen Beschluss geht was eigentlich
dieser Rat der Kommandeure der
wagnergruppe tut falls ihn plötzlich zu
Tode kommt aber sind eben ein Teil der
wagnergruppe gerade in Belarus ein Teil
ist in Afrika ein Teil ist in Russland
und sollte sich in die russischen
Streitkräfte integrieren es bleibt die
Frage offen wie handlungsfähig die
eigentlich sind und was aus dieser
Haltung die sie ausgedrückt haben auf
Telegramm gegen die russische Führung
auch gegen was daraus wird ob die
tatsächlich etwas unternehmen können das
werden wir glaube ich erst in den
nächsten Tagen sehen einige haben gesagt
sie haben sich aus Belarus in Richtung
Russland in Bewegung gesetzt aber wir
können da im Moment noch nicht sehen
oder wirklich was beobachten und der Rat
der Kommandeure selbst hat sich noch in
keiner Weise geäußert darüber was die
wagnergruppe jetzt eigentlich vor hat
oder Teile der wagnergruppe Vorhaben ich
glaube das müssen wir abwarten und das
werden wir weiter beobachten vielen Dank
Nicole lange Militär und
Sicherheitsexperte danke für die
Einschätzung und die Antworten auf die
vielen Fragen heute